so next we currently have from Harvard
Thank You Sean for the introduction and
thank you for inviting me to share some
of our work how we going to attack code
communication challenges when we apply
this utilization for recertification
problem in cyber physical system so this
is a joint work with a few people and
syndra was a student in kth and it's
going to join my group at the postdoc
and children to was a postdoc but going
to start as a professor in university of
central florida and Carla was a faculty
in kth and why hit was a colleague in
Harvard but now it's in token averse
team so to motivate is a work I want to
start with a discussion of Internet of
Things I said when the word first come
out enough things a lot of people
including myself think
McNulty is more like a bad word but now
we look around we do have more and more
devices that are connected and this is
the number how many devices are
connected like you can think about
yourself you probably have a multiple
computer multiple tablet and multiple
even multiple cell phones and plus the
smart home device it's projected by 2020
probably every person on average will
have like seven device that's connected
through the internet or different
communication protocols so why we want
to connect the device we want to improve
the quality of life from the position
control point of view how are we going
to define the quality of life if we are
able to formulate a deposition problem
so we would like to maximize the social
welfare and also to make sure the system
is operating safely and somehow we can
cause like the quality of services since
there is a huge network connected now
you can imagine how we're going to
coordinate so then a lot of paper in
djibouti organizations that have been
promoted to handle the challenges in the
large scale of Internet of Things or
smile grace my city so no matter whether
it is like radial structure
by radio structure here the orange arrow
means the communication as is a control
center talk to individual device I will
a device talk to each other to negotiate
what a decision a common theme that we
usually assume to apply to teacher
evaluation as we assume the device can
communicate talk to each other
computed decision and communicate and
he'll they kind of reach a point they
agree on to take the action so the
assumption is a iterative two-way
communication and we can trust the
communication so and this is typically
how we going to analyze the performance
we're going to have some opposition
problem like Social Welfare to maximize
and the some a question we want to
satisfy was it's a dynamical constraint
or stationary constraint and over the
controllable variables like some device
we can content something wise we cannot
change and queuing information of the
external input for example the
disturbance uncertainties how much
demand we need to generate to make sure
everyone has electricity to use how much
generation from the renewable energy so
that would because the external input
too useful apart we knew we need some
information and we also need a
communication what's the challenges or
difficulty when we talk to all industry
people can you adopt my method and then
we look at the practical things of the
problem if we just applied approach in
real system in the real step of physical
system like the first challenge about
the sensing part for the same thing if
we really want to know what the exact
people going to do for the next hour
it's very hard and it will be delayed
information will be inaccurate and
secondly when we try to do the modeling
that you've even we assume ok now we're
not dealing with human we're dealing
with the physical plant we having
actresses and models as always and we
have heard many parks talking about we
have uncertainty about actuator and
studying about system modelling how is
it going to affect our performance and
the last one like this part will focus
on
is a communication challenges so many of
you heard about a lot of people working
on the factory because a lot of
communication and challenges and the
existing protocols here no matter what
kind of communication protocols we're
going to use we face different hi-po of
challenges noise package loss long delay
using the power line communication has
limited pantywaist like and now people
talking about separate security so what
we care about those because like this is
a famous picture from the satellite
capturing the nose is black cow in 2003
so when we try to really call it a
device the the voltage is we can achieve
better efficiency like help each other
but the SATA effect if we're not
designing our algorithm method well it
will also publicize the passages so if a
few decisions happen as same time it's
very easy to lead to a system level
cascading failure in a very short time
period so test motivate is a recent work
in real time opposition that's kind of
fit into the theme of this workshop
would have been bad that so last time
when during the society workshop a
societal network workshop where in Seoul
is picture multiple times so we reused
opposition just as a feed-forward open
loop scenario like getting some
information of the system including the
disturbance take operational algorithm
learnt how each device what we're going
to take
so either we call this an open loop
control we use the operation
feed-forward scenario now people
sometimes say okay we can implement it
in a real-time fashion of it feedback
fashion what does it mean is so this is
the physical networks we can have all
the devices
taking the sensing and once I have the
information I can tell out actuators
what are we going to do so you probably
wondering I come kind of putting the
different like multiple arrow here does
this kind of capture in the
communication channel so if I just
locally my sensors device at the sensor
and to the controller now you can
sometimes people refer as a fully
decentralized and that will have limited
ability so then we can use a
communication channel that's the
difference since I talk to each other so
this is the worry nice pictures can
adjust certain limitations as I
mentioned before for example we can just
focus on the sensing like measured
measurement as is easy to measure like
the state variable instead of
disturbance variables and since it's a
feedback control so even we have an
accuracy of the system model it's still
current here certain performance but
this is another challenge that we see
some talks on Tuesday about the
communication challenges through the
communication channel so what do I'm
going to show is like first I will show
how we can kind of use the physical
measurement to reduce some communication
but then if we want to further reduce
communication then we need to confess
and think about the coding coding skips
the question list you is what is that
exactly the minimal needs of the
communication if we understand that well
so what we can think about communication
protocols we should redesign what come
the resource we should put so this is a
high level of the big picture how we're
going to combine the real-time decision
making with improvements in the
communication protocols - talk I will
focus on a simple problem that has
different applications so it's a
resource education province and many of
you have been saying it's many times
because it's in different community we
have a kind of common structure for the
problem I figured that we're a very
simple one so we have a different device
or users and everyone has their like
ideal picture of what they want to
consume and they can also have the local
constraint like lower power Apapa and
this some control center and broke has
some information to coordinate that is a
limited resource like the X is how much
resource consumed by individual device I
so now the question is we're going to
use a communication standing
mission over iteratively price my
request and to coordinate so this is a
very standard test book now you mean
test book so worse than the textbook
framework for the jewelry certification
and what I want to show like as I
mentioned a lot of application like
talking about smart grid building
control data center data center trying
to coordinate the power consumption from
different servers and this is actually
the I like put one on chip design so
even now people from the GPU design CPU
design they come to talk to me okay
I also want to reduce communication we
had to coordinate if I can transistors
can we do that and also especially for
the communication like our area it's a
lot of reallocation profits so what I'm
going to show so these are like this
some brief introduction in case some of
you who didn't see this problem before
so why I say this problem is a
well-structured and because we
understand the province of optimality of
the algorithm like woody because as it
of solution you won't have the closed
form of almost everything so if we have
this kind of from the primal domain to
do order man so this our resource
allocation problem when we take the two
older men so these are dual problem we
look at the dual problem that you're
very simple form has a like to this is
if you assume also assembly is a
strongly convex concave function and
this sector we can also see is a convex
pessimist poverty and this is roughly
like I put the dual function structure
but what it really matters I want to say
is that walk away diem method so by
using the dual function what were able
to do is the control control center
update the price signal according to the
door isn't individual user I get in the
press information take their maximum or
optimal decision under that price
information and send information back
and I want to highlight here is so this
is happen to be the to gradient so very
simple scheme and that's why in practice
is
easy-to-use so the question I'm going to
pose is this so now think about it
because I was saying the communication
even we'll assume we think this
communication among other devices but
now when you think about for the
building even for this room is all the
lights really connected to somewhere we
don't know probably it's not so when we
talk about connect all the device or
smart device the first question people
were saying no like is a lot of
investment on the communication channels
so first our question can we just reduce
the communication need like instead of
sending some requests back can we try a
one-way communication to broadcast a
second Allah is like how many bit we
really need to broadcast and if we can
reduce the bit it will open up different
kind of resource we can use to implement
algorithm so how are we going to do it
quadrant so far for this one so great
good
so let's look at the province structure
the carbon over here so this is a dual
Korean tea Sun that we implement if we
assume everyone can negotiate negotiate
and take action so somehow it so first
the first question we look at what
occurs it will create decent information
at the summation of X I so what this
means is if I individual device take the
action and if I can measure the total
consumption this always happens like the
Building Control or even the wireless
communication I know how many resource
is being used so I don't need people to
report information to me I can detect
action once I take the action so that
one means like now I can just book has
information of the price but I need
people to take the action so now let's
think about further reduce the
communication so how we're going to
further use the communication like what
I'm a is what exciting emissions was
sent to coordinate
gotta hear that if you have a me I can't
tell me is
okay since we look at the average
themself it's just the difference
between how much resource is consumed
and how much resource is available so
what is that the matter is exhaust value
doesn't play really independence but
role the difference are the sign of the
difference play a more important role so
we can just send a white bit to indicate
the sign and I suggest I'm going to
movement in this way so like since I own
it's an indicator
so any visual device can run some local
estimator okay I got something and I
would say now the resource question is
violated or not violated and then I'm
able to kind of run some look at the
meter and I take the action so does
suggest for these schemes so only use
one piece communication one page one-way
communication so control center take the
measurement if is larger than that
direction is smaller than the other
direction and individual users instead
of just taking like to this calculation
also around some localized tomater and
to update the price information
I would cure is right so what exactly
the performance for the algorithm and
again this actually look into the
opposition textbook now people ready
read a textbook about this mastered
because for the one dimension a cert
Lisa turns out just be a normal nice
gradient descent method so with a
normalize Korean descent so these are
position problem I'm trying to minimize
and each time instead of taking the
gradient direction I'm taking the
normalized gradient direction and
there's some a step size you can choose
if it's one dimension list become a one
bit you just need what is part of an
active information
so this is all the party message suggest
this work so now this is like finally
come to the mathematical problem I'm
going to talk about so now let's just
focus on the tool problem itself and as
I said that the dual problem but every
time remember the dual problem had a
primal problem corresponding to the dual
problem and so the top power had this
structure convex and Al smooth because
it come from the primal problem of
Nutini function is strongly convex so
what are we going to focus on is in
general also I talked about the one
dimension case to say how it's going to
be implemented in reality it's always
high dimension case we have a multiple
resource we need to coordinate so first
I will talk about if I do the
quantization on the gradient descent
direction to understand how much
connotation is needed and first let's
just focus on the simple case tell me
where ins one to understand the
complication complexity like what we
heard on Tuesday is if you allow them to
do the tongue variant communication what
this means is as like control center Y
coding from encoding information I kind
of had all the kind of history
information and I can do that hung
worrying codeine codeine soo bahk has a
delta and people can use in the
information to update as a question for
this one what is the minimal number of
bit this is able to make my
recertification problem going to work
what do I mean by that is algorithm can
converge to the optimal solution with
certain accuracy so I put the here is
like for this scenario we focus on the
normalized direction because we didn't
make any further assumption on the
product abundance or this is so we've
normalized the so we just normalized
like only you need unit sphere and for
this one so far we have a of the
solution for the one dimension case and
furthermore what dimension case were
still working on that questions for this
general problems set up
so it's actually has a lot of literature
in this work so in the depolarization
people think about colonization a lot
and for the quantization so this is the
sound work I want to highlight the last
one so the last one is actually one paid
seppuku Alliant mastered for deep neural
network and apparently it's a implement
like Imperial Coll the paper had a lot
of empirical study like if you do the
one-page great supper gradient descent
you will speed up the process by like a
lot a large degree so you can say it's
not just paralyzation you need talking
about communication because sometimes
the communication will be the bottleneck
of the speed of the algorithm and this
is on Tuesday we heard a lot of talk
when we control dynamical system how we
go in to handle the communication
challenges or the fundamental limit and
I want to highlight this part work
because some of our definition is
motivated by this line of work
example in 1987 so john Sizzix
and the lord they have a province that
if had two processors and everyone had
like processor one processor two had a
gradual function how many number of pisa
need to communicate to solve that to
personalization problem and this is from
computer science community for digital
computing if you have a make data a
different kind of processor how you can
how many bits needed to compute a
function and recently people from the
machine learning extend all those study
to the size of the inference problem
how many communication is needed if you
want to apply like understand the next
aesthetics of the data so let's go to
the result so what we can find
what kind of fundamental performance we
can have for the first simple story the
time you weren't gradient descent so
what do I mean by the fundamental limit
so this is a quantization and what
the conversation before I really
implement everything I don't have much
knowledge about what users and dealing
with the roughly information public get
is okay it's if I simply strongly convex
I kind of say I public have some
information about what is a so how
strong compacted it is probably act that
so I say when we say that when a queue
weighs a good quantization what we mean
by that is to anchor themselves
shouldn't work for any well behaved
Robin and since the problem is coming
from the research education problem like
a fake example for this case it's convex
and L smooth so that the question we put
so what kind of quantization can works
for every problem that well behaved and
there's a few questions we want to ask
is the following how are we going to
determine like my connotation schema
going to work no matter what kind of
problem going to have I secondly is what
is a minimal size of the quantization
like we want to understand the
fundamental limit what is the minimum
number of bit and once if I have those
kind of solution how can I come in DT
and how to truth step size given the
proper condensation and another like if
I have more resource like I can use more
peace than one bit
how the additional information can help
to improve the performance of the
algorithm so your questions
yes this can be yes yes yeah so I will
come back to the test question and
discussion after my talk it's there's a
reason we pick this one yeah good
questions
that's a question we want to understand
so like now you look at the problem some
of you probably think it's worry
familiar right so this is a tiny
Americanization like it's very kind of
image interpretation dynamic cooperation
algorithm but it looks very like
straightforward so and the truth yes so
the intuition we have for this one is
the descent direction so take any
authorization passbook when you look at
the Sun Direction what it means is so
this is the mechanization direction and
this is my like current gradient
direction so I love us they are close to
each other meet the angle close to each
other I take this instead of the true
green and direction if you don't work
yes so by doing that you can definitely
prove the sufficient condition that's a
further condition what I mean is if it's
a decent direction then I can guarantee
the algorithm going to converge but the
interesting question we were thinking
about is is this actually the necessary
condition so turns out is if and only if
so what this means is here we divide the
city cover and the city cover basically
just means for your contrast direction
for any kind of vector in its domain you
can find a quantized direction that is
close like the city is smaller than I
would
so as I one direction - poof it's going
to work is easy and the other one why
this is the only way so it's that also
easy because you can we can easily come
out some kinetic example if it's not
such violence like see the cover poverty
you can always pick culture the one
example and you can pick one direction
because the direction will be always
like far away from other contact
direction and then you consider starting
from this hole and this value you will
always be can't evade from the optimal
solution so this is like intuitive but
the question is based on tasks I'm
standing how I'm going to design a
connotation skin so this is a some
example what kind of connotation come to
works going to work so the first one is
a like the very popular one people have
been using like the one-page subgradient
in for the tip neuron is taking the sign
of the gradient direction and this is
definitely a once it'll cover but that's
not a minimal one so once you go into
the high dimension vector case so this
is actually you didn't use any kind of
joint information between like while you
are different dimension so this is
actually the minimal proper condensation
so this is one so what week why to first
explain what is the colonization so you
just take all the normal basis and then
just add another vector and this is
going to be a proper condensation memy
is a stock cover but how we prove its a
mini mode because you can prove if the
quantization
Karianna D is smaller than k plus one
it's always going to fail and then this
one the Coriana d is k plus one then you
know this actually the minimum propyl
condensation and what is the message it
means is you only need lock to k plus
one page at each iteration and the case
the dimension of the problem so you can
say once you go to the higher dimension
the problem is has a long dimension
property like symmetry for the upper
stock like was how your problem could be
many other mesh of the part
so this is the example of the CD cover
and the minimal quantization so next
interesting question is how it goes
acidity is going to affect my colonial
sweet
so we have a different type of commerce
race result depending your optimality
criterion so this is the one primary the
criterion that because at the optimal
solution the gradient should take
roughly equal should be equal zero and
so like we pick the absolute as my
stopping criterion so for this Ramos's
mix is given a coaster subset so here we
focus on concepts eyes focus on concepts
eyes and there exists that tea make sure
the PT the current value satisfy this
optimality criterion and the tea is
upper bounded by this one so you
probably want I would exert how I'm
going to read it I'm going to show you
what the message form this communist
rate result offers the proof is like
intuitive because we have a design
direction you can guarantee the DC value
will already decreasing if I'm like
gradients is larger than absolute so
what the intuition like what's the
interpretation from the result from here
I was trying to calculate hit what is
the optimal for example the optimal step
size by optimal I want to minimize the
upper bound so rough I take the optimal
step size and call this kind of tea
sensor we have some other common as a
result so roughly you can interpret it
in the other way come on as rate of my
solution the coerced array of the
solution a holla here is a one-hour
scrub
so now compared with a non-contrast
version at the optimal master if you
sinestro you have one over T square if
you do the constant gradient descent is
1 over T and because the condensation is
behaved similar like sub gradient method
one was for of T and that's how much we
lose by quantizing information and
roughly but you can continue adding more
information to think about how much
speed up we can have in this particular
situation when you pick your gamma is
constant for me change the gamma to be
the time varying why right that's what
idea yes yeah yeah but I don't think
this longer change much for this one
yeah good point
yes here I only had like a me for my
quantized direction right for here I
have a smoothness the Somoza means the
gradient is ellipses so it's not that
kind of like not well-behaved so for me
it's a great unconscious gradient like
the grain direction is a steepest
descent direction
[Music]
taking points they can point up to but
yeah if you're talking about the X and X
tech start matter it seems to quantize
one good point almost directly away yeah
so here we select for the proof I mean
like we used like the objective value to
prove it because for the strong convex
case if the story will be simpler so
here we only have smoothly not strong
convex that's why like to see what
talking about like I point to the value
function decent Direction not really
like aligned with X minus XT Model X
star so but the intuition for the proof
we look at a function value and then to
prove that if my gradient is not in like
if if I have enough gradient information
right then just means like even have a
wrong information of the gradient
I can still current here's a descent
direction but if I'm like my gradient
implements already where is more and
then if I have a little bit erosion that
will be like like a big problem for me
to really along the descent direction
that's why for here if you if we want
exact recoveries of more solution
the gamma step size of the decreasing
the color step size you will always
converge to the optimal solution with
certain kind of wrench to the
convergence point and it might be a
smaller number of quantization please
so dads will show up for the second part
talk when we go into the town we are in
because because that integration happens
right so then work out how we're going
to allow that I will show because why
single dimension because we have a sum
like me max definition I will show that
later
good question so but before before I
move from the second topic so now
because here you can see how my
quantization the company number beat
going to affect my performance
convergence rate is through the CD cover
and the sitter however if you really
want to find the exact connection
between the communist rate and the
number of beat is going to the like
channels theorem to the severe covering
like because this is kind of cedar cover
and how many star cover you need to do
it like we I'm not going to talk about
this in his talk and this is some
simulation without it's oh it's on I
realized so since I studied the
application in power system always
simulation results further than my
theory and so further for the simulation
so we took a connector to dimension to
see how it's performed so we have a two
count to two infinite Pandavas like
means nong con highest algorithm so this
one the steepest one is just a gradient
descent and the other one this one is
the quantized knockin heads are
normalized because it is normalized is
slower so you look at here the four bit
per iteration the same algorithm address
like quantize the each iteration the
four bit matches the infinite bandwidth
if I send that information looks like
there a lot information Prescott wasted
a from the simulation result could even
I couldn't read how the difference
between the normalized green discerned
and the contrast version
so doesn't like as our predict upper
bound would be higher than its value so
but let me to the okay before the second
topic I want to put this on mother like
to see the some messages I want you guys
kinda to take home is because I show you
the nice result ex-official necessary
how it's going to affect the Communists
rate and when we're going to talk
talking about the real problem because
the tool problem from the cyber physical
system always has additional constraint
at least should it be positive so where
as a constraint and then to think about
can we have a similarly fundamental
result like can the resolve
unconstrained case extent is that the
same direction going to work so like how
many of you think it's going to work
okay some of it's a question or you
think so okay it's not going to work and
I think the intuition come from the
discussion we just had is because of the
constraint you can construct a kind of
worst case so is well so like this is
the different direction and it's a
quantized like direction so this is a
gradient direction so it can't get stuck
at an optimal if this one and this one
is also gonna and for this one is not
necessary to be a descent direction
anymore because my constraints like this
is my gradient descent direction and I
will take this one as my quantized
direction but since I will come straight
to the projection I go alone it's like
so it's not this interaction anymore so
it's not going to work like it's kind of
bummer like how I'm going to use my
master to deal with a real application a
good aeneas
the popular quantized master has taken
the sum the gradient is going to work so
like this is example this is the dual
problem so all you to read
even worried about the constraint is
like the positive that that type of
constraint and so the so this is the
like project it to a gradient descent
and taking the Sun so this master is
going to work and similar communist the
rate will hold for the something I want
to highlight so probably you're
wondering meters gradient descent is
such a simple method how easily really
work for the more complicated system but
all the intuition help us to design one
control mastered for the voltage control
had on more dynamics like larger scale
had a more decision variable and for
this one we have a one-page
communication for the water to control
individual networks so interesting like
it's on my web page for this paper
finally we go to the more entry like
mathematical interesting problem for the
time war in colonization I only have a
five or seven minute
yeah stop I think the most important I
want to go through is the definition so
so this is the this our resource
allocation problem so I pre it back
because this additional originally
owning kind of okay this is a primal
variable P is larger than zero that's
good enough I if you study this a lot of
apathy I'm saying tell me okay it is
also bounded you can add a like boundary
information so the boundless of the dual
variable helped us a lot to study the
problem so what do I mean by that so now
let's look at the fundamental limit when
we allow the colonization be time
varying so this is a problem class we're
going to focus on to our problem
converse l smooth so this is our
conversation scheme let's go let me go
through this so the quantization like
the what the information sent will
depend on the history and the sadati can
changing and the Qt like how many in
peat you use per time can change as will
like this time you want for the more
information you put more information you
can also read the information so we put
all the colonization class as the Q P
and the Q P the P here is the this one
so I kind of assume the P information is
available for me I can use that to the
my connotation skin and so this is the
like any kind of cedar function they put
here so we thought that is put them into
the set so the question we're going to
ask is these questions so first we call
it epsilon complexity so absolute
complexity means if I want to achieve
absolute optimality
what's a minimum number of pit and the B
complex what I mean is if I have a big
bit available was a optimal way to use
it like what kind of the optimal
technology so this is the intuition for
the data of what we have in our mind
and mathematically how is translate is
to here so I'm only putting this
stopping criterion we have other part of
optimality criterion in the problem so
take this problem so this is the optimal
set because we don't assemble strong
converse it can be a set of the optimal
solution and so this is my current P so
we try to ask the question so that's
what our definition for absent
complexity if I go through is its Adam
in Max definition so the other cell is
follow from the communication complexity
in literature so what is the means is
you take any quantization any problem if
I want to achieve this optimality then
we'll use certain number of bit so we
I'm doing the like what is the worst
case like the worst problem that will
make the bit be large and then for this
wise like I want to find the optimal
quantization scheme to against those
kind of risk I'm going to have so this
kind of worst case in this narrow it
kind of the worst case definition like
what kind of worst problem going to make
a mechanization going to fill like
roughly means minimum number bit to
achieve a zone of Madi for every poverty
question for the definition that I just
want to get the definition be clear
okay so I will just wanna say like we
have a result for this one so it's
actually lock
whoa Absalom so bad luck absolutely okay
what the exact guys means some skip the
proof like for the disapprove actually
very useful it's happening in many
leadership but I want to have at least
one no true ability so what the girl is
that you mean so why it's a tawanda
mention case we're different from the
high dimension case for the smooth our
president problem so last I didn't talk
about P complexity but you can change
this one to another because this is
means if I if I want to achieve absolute
complexity how many beats I need if I
just say the commonness rate coverage
rate means is how close I am to the
optimal solution if I using peep it it's
going to be one over two to the power of
P that is the absolution kavadis rate so
what I want to highlight is this is like
because we know the optimal commanders
rate for the creation based master like
I'm talking about grading based method
for the smooth function is what what
here but we have a kind of better
convergence rate what happening because
for this one I like the panelist player
import in the row and it is also one
dimension you can trust to the back
section search but the question is how
you going to design a quantization to
allow the following users to do the type
of pet section search and this is a
connotation scheme that we designed an
interesting thing is so the definition
we allow can wear in history although
like under changing rate for this one is
the Condor different scheme you Daniel
use the history it's only based on the
current gradient direction so the tea is
a green and direction and just make
based on the current the gradient
direction to kind of certain level by
section search and it's not going to
work you don't need the using history
and turns out this is actually kind of
not as tambourine it's almost like
time-invariant different scheme
two minute yeah too many because I want
to there's another more interest in fact
we can talk about several physical
system I asked people to take action and
I have a limited resource
did something happen it is like it's
well wildly the hard physical constraint
right if people take action I haven't
really like find a cooler solution how
it going to wala is a constraint so how
are we going to make sure the physical
constraint can be in short during the
transient this is a much harder question
so we want to make sure the primal
feasibility anytime is going to be
feasible and this Y is like much harder
than what I present before and sometimes
the intuition it doesn't work like the
proof is more non-intuitive
so I wanna say is like we have a
optional complexity for the primal
feasible colonization the primal
feasible colonization is I want
accommodation we always meet the primal
action always be feasible as it's a very
different result because look here it's
become infinite it's an impossibility
result if you want to promote visibility
you shouldn't do in the colonization now
time talk about the proof but there's
another good message for the primal
feasibility is if you change your path
of optimality criterion you actually are
able to do something the tongue worrying
colonization gonna do work if I only
care about objective value not like
action it back to Joe's question and so
this community really is like 1 over P
so like similarly to the smooth
polarization problem like 1 over T so
these are the worried surprising and and
this is a conversation scheme it's not
an intuitive
it's the intuition to come from some
other study what kind of natural
condition we have like to make sure it
won't be like primal feasible I don't
have time to talk about that but you
were probably interesting to see the
simulation result so is if the problem
so the problem we pick the duopa boat
had even actually had a strongly convex
property the quantized version in
practice that way i said it's always
works better than the theory into the
primal feasible quantization you still
have the linear convergence rate
and you can always guarantee the
visibility to the transient dynamics
that just concluded my talk and there's
a lot of like following work to really
talk about the replication the loop
especially the robustness of this
problem thank you so much but you come
against therefore we take my question